sounds a great change in your future
destiny has dire plans for you my friend
I have daughter plans for destiny
I love the goddess the gap is invaded as
God I hope will be glad see me
and so this day
we'll be reborn - neither stopper here
now content ragnarok the end of
everything
so I put it together team
at the old age
[Music]
the prize
I see
I don't know TQ something wrong
he's a fighter
papa
I'm not a cream or a monster
you gotta sit there
what were you the god of again
I do not wanna know young by saying your
life
just a couple hot-headed fools my whole
clock raging fire oh I like smoldering
fire
holy crap everybody they put dr. strange
in the trailer what I think is going on
here is this is sort of like a different
version of the comic-con trailer
obviously it's international that's why
you hear the voice over in it and it
just made to be a little more linear a
little easier to follow for non-english
speaking audiences so typically like if
you look at the different posters that
they market around the world in
different countries the movies all the
movies get marketed in slightly
different ways so the last couple of
years what you started to see is that
the domestic marketing like inside the
United States tends to be more character
based in the international stuff the
posters the trailers all just tend to
hype up the big action set-pieces so
like we'll probably eventually get a
surger poster that will probably be
international before you see it
domestically but if you don't remember
Doctor Strange is a part of Thor
Ragnarok if you didn't know before you
definitely know now from this trailer
but they haven't really revealed how big
a part of it he is he's critical to
finding Odin just from that tag at the
end of the Doctor Strange movie so if
you don't remember just turning the
timeline Thor's hair is a good way to
benchmark where he's at in the movie
when he meets with Doctor Strange watch
list of individuals and beings from
other realms that may be a threat to
this world shirt opted brother Loki is
one of those beings were the inclusion
yeah
so why bring him here to New York a
little bit long story
family drama the kind of thing but we're
looking for my father
okay so if you found oh then you'd all
return to Asgard promptly oh yes
promptly to help you so I think they
said that he has long hair in Ragnarok
for about a third of the movie so you
have to assume that this is relatively
early and he's trying to track down Odin
then he runs afoul of hella she destroys
his hammer and kicks him across to the
other side of the universe to Sekar but
it does sound like they'll be 15 20
minutes of old Thor and then he meeting
with dr. strange and it sounds like that
might not totally get resolved till the
end of the movie because like you see
this action set piece where he's
fighting hella using Odin's spear it's
totally badass this is going to be so
awesome but why is he wielding it and
not Odin meaning that Odin probably
hasn't come back yet
and what they've said so far about him
in the movie Odin specifically is that
he's sort of on earth doesn't understand
that he's Odin they've done something to
him to confuse him it is because Loki
has been ruling Asgard pretending to be
him it sounds like Loki was responsible
for putting him on earth and taking his
memories away so you have one of the
most powerful people in the universe
running around earth like a vagrant Thor
has no idea how to find him that's where
Doctor Strange comes in but because of
this last big action set piece where it
looks like he's almost become the rune
King it's basically the most powerful
form of Thor that Thor has ever been in
the comics he's still fighting hella
they haven't completely blown Asgard to
bits it still looks relatively intact
but all of them standing on the Rainbow
Bridge facing hella before he comes down
infused with the power of the hammer or
the odinforce or whatever power he has
seems like it's connected to the moment
where Hulk is fighting Fenris wolf and
we don't really know where this surger
scene happens but it sounds like it's
also relatively late in the movie - like
things go crazy they have the adventure
on Sekar then they escape and try to
stop hella but obviously they're hyping
the big showdown of this movie as the
culmination of destiny and Thor's like I
have other
fans for destiny as if it's the destiny
of Asgard to be destroyed and reborn so
if you're going to have owed and come
back in the movie it's probably going to
be connected to something like this so
even though they will touch on Odin
stuff early in the movie I'm not
expecting him to be around to like very
very late in the game but otherwise most
of the footage in this is relatively
similar to the comic-con trailer just
like slightly different moments from the
same scenes you saw in that there's a
little more dialogue from the characters
and obviously like the biggest
difference is that dr. strange scene at
the beginning and I don't think that
happens right at the beginning I think
it is put at the top of the trailer
because they want people to get really
crazy about the idea of Doctor Strange
popping up and have you been following
Kevin Feige comments about how phase 3
phase 4 phase 5 you know whatever it
comes after phase 4 is going to be
different you're going to start seeing
more of this because Doctor Strange is a
pretty cool character he's one of the
most powerful characters in the Marvel
Universe but they just aren't as many
people that are hyped up to go see a
doctor Strange movie is say another Iron
Man movie or a Spider Man movie or even
a Thor movie so how do you get people
even more excited about the team-up
movies and these spin-off characters you
put them in other people's movies and
you get pairings that you normally
wouldn't see like normally this would
just be another Thor movie it would just
be Thor characters but now they're
stepping all these other people into
each other's movies and I think it's
only going to help them down the road
especially when they try to introduce
even more new characters like Captain
Marvel so what will happen is is because
I've already talked a lot about Infinity
Ward all the comic-con information they
drop the scrolls secret invasion
theories I'll link those videos at the
end of this my infinity war trailer so
just a reminder again the defenders is
dropping on Friday I was originally
going to do a defenders trailer video
but then this drops it's like oh my god
Doctor Strange in a freaking Thor
trailer looks like defenders is coming
tomorrow so I still need to post my
non-spoilery defenders review I've only
seen the first four episodes but once it
actually does drop then I'll start
posting the spoilery episode videos
they'll leave all your requests in the
comments below I know there hasn't been
as much comic book stuff lately but
that's just because Game of Thrones and
Rick and Morty are priorities because
they're on the air right now
new defenders coming soon so be sure to
subscribe to get everything why you guys
wait for that you can click here for all
my marvel trailer
from comic-con including infinity war
and you can click here for brand new
game of thrones thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight